[Music]
this week we are broadcasting our shows
in virtual reality
thanks to our good friends at AT&T
that's right you can watch our show in
VR via Conan cardboard and other VR
devices we have a for Conan 360 cameras
placed all over this theater you can see
the show from any angle it's pretty
impressive show Mandy alright strapping
in alright alright let's take it oh hi
Conan yeah oh look at how I look at how
big you look yeah
okay let's cycle through the camera so
people can see that's pretty impressive
yeah yeah okay there it is
[Applause]
hey buddy what's going on pal hey guy
rookie knowledge you in any way what's
going on he refuses to acknowledge you a
hi friend
yeah what's your name buddy very nice
clearly someone flee the long arm of the
law so a little shy it wasn't paid taxes
go back to the other one says I wanna go
me Wow yeah lose a few
oh hi you brought your luggage okay Andy
you look like an idiot I do oh my god I
just saw myself I do yeah anyway it's as
if you're in the actual theater Andy it
really is it's so much more real than
actually being yeah
now those of you at home with headsets
can go to team koco.com slash new 60 to
experience all of this if you like
thanks for friends at AT&T for
sponsoring conan 360 we're gonna take a
quick break when we come back the cast
is silicon valley